The most important thing if you can do all those things is that the other guy
has to not know what you're doing.
That was George Saint Pierre is greatest trend.
Correct.
He never knew when he was punching you or he's taking you down and you were
always,
you were always behind.
Koscheck yes.
Jab in the double it.
So fucking good at that here and that and he's not the best wrestler and he's
not the best striker,
but he was the best at figuring out how to do things.
You didn't know what was coming next,
where,
where you were overloaded for Rasa,
hobby and him or a phenomenal combination cause for Ross is so intellectually so
smart and he's thinking rationally.
He's not like,
you're going to go in there and you're gonna fuck him up.
None of that.
Some of the problems,
it's all about overloading his mind.
It was all very rational,
very technique based,
very psychology based.
But the reason that what made that GSP so good also is,
um,
he,
you,
you didn't know what he was doing,
but he was facing that high level competition to construct Matt Hughes with
Pico.
All these guys.
He goes,
oh,
I don't need to use my restaurant and knocking on with the body shot this guy
with him,
Kraus,
you're going to see the best version of in Pico cause he can't just sit there
and fucking box of them.
You can see his wrestling.
I bet you're going to see some different mix it up.
Cause he's never been pushed.
He's dominating.
Do you remember what John Danner told us the secret to GSPS.
Do you remember that?
Was that when we're eating at that restaurant,
he had hair.
John did.
He goes,
he said the secret to his success is it's super simple.
He's gonna either faint,
he's either going to thank a jab or he's going to actually really jab you or
faint take down or actually take,
take you down.
So that was always a faint before everything.
Yeah,
he goes,
he just,
he's always still in fentanyl.
So you never know when that shot's coming.
My Pico de,
well,
there was the whole thing for asa hobbies just so the two of them together
worked so well because they both have a great check of their ego and an
understanding of the consequences and you barely through write his name mark and
they're both really smart and they're both really,
really told me cause he's trying with them all the time.
Said that he's an amazing chess player.
Uh,
George George is an amazing,
so he's really strategic and I feel like he could always find these out empty
where,
where are you?
Where are you had a weakness near them and that's where he was.
Well he was super open minded to men.
I mean,
didn't need like learn back kicked from you are like,
yes,
like he just found easy place.
I felt so embarrassed that I'm,
uh,
I'm like,
I just felt like it was ridiculous that I'm going to show him anything.
There's video on youtube of Joe Rogan,
GSP,
but you know what I fucking kicking lesson.
I knew I wouldn't ever have tried to sell it to him if I didn't have anything.
But when they're,
that came out of that same meeting with Donna her when we were in the restaurant
Donaher her set it up cause he goes,
I'm looking for,
and he told me afterwards that he set me up.
He kinda had heard.
So He's like,
I'm looking for someone to teach GSP how to throw a tuning sidekick.
His technique is off.
It's like we're in a fucking James Bond movie or something that's funny with his
accent.